qui déforme nos perceptions, et qui brouille nos pensées.
Elle nous fait croire à tort qu'on ne se soucie pas de nous
Elle nous empêche de joindre les autres,
elle nous fait nous demander : "pourquoi s'exposer au rejet et à la souffrance
alors que notre cœur nous fait déjà bien trop souffrir ?"
J'étais en proie à la vraie solitude, à l'époque,
mais, étant entouré par des gens toute la journée, je n'ai pas compris.
Mais la solitude n'est définie que subjectivement.
Elle n'existe que si on se sent
émotionnellement ou socialement déconnecté de notre entourage.
Et je me sentais déconnecté.
Il y a beaucoup d'études sur la solitude, et c'est horrifiant.
La solitude ne se contente pas de rendre malheureux, elle est mortelle.
Je ne plaisante pas.
La solitude chronique augmente les risques de décès prématuré
de 14%.
La solitude augmente la pression sanguine et le cholestérol.
Elle arrête même le système immunitaire,
nous rendant vulnérable à toutes sortes de maladies et infections.
En fait, les scientifiques ont prouvé qu'en tout,
la solitude chronique est aussi nocive
pour votre santé à long terme et notre longévité que la cigarette.
Les paquets de cigarettes ont des mises en garde :
« Ceci peut vous tuer »
Mais la solitude n'en a pas.
C'est pourquoi il faut que nous laissions la priorité à notre santé psychologique,
que nous ayons une hygiène émotionnelle.
Parce qu'on ne peut pas soigner une blessure psychologique
si on ne sait même pas qu'on est blessé.
La solitude n'est pas la seule blessure psychologique
qui déforme nos perceptions et qui nous trompe.
L'échec le fait aussi.
Une fois, j'ai visité une garderie,
où j'ai vu trois bambins jouer avec des jouets en plastique identiques.
Il fallait faire glisser le bouton rouge et un joli toutou sortait de la boite.
Une petite fille a essayé de tirer le bouton violet, puis d'appuyer dessus,
et elle s'est assise en regardant la boite avec les lèvres qui tremblaient.
Le petit garçon à côté d'elle a vu ce qui était arrivé,
s'est tourné vers sa boîte et il a fondu en larmes sans même la toucher.
Pendant ce temps, une autre petite essayait tout ce qu'elle pouvait
jusqu'à ce qu'elle fasse glisser le bouton rouge.
Le mignon toutou est sorti, et elle gazouillait de plaisir.
Donc trois bambins, avec des jouets identiques
mais une réaction à l'échec très différente.
Les deux premiers étaient capables de faire glisser un bouton rouge.
La seule chose qui les a empêché de réussir,
c'est que leur esprit leur a fait croire qu'ils ne pouvaient pas réussir.
Les adultes aussi se font avoir comme ça, tout le temps.
En fait, nous avons un ensemble par défaut de sentiments et croyances, qui fait feu
à chaque fois que nous nous heurtons à la frustration et aux incidents.
Savez-vous comment votre esprit réagit à l'échec ?
Il faut que vous le sachiez.
Si votre cerveau veut vous convaincre que vous êtes incapable de faire quelque chose
et si vous le croyez,
alors vous allez vous sentir sans défense, comme ces deux bambins,
et vous arrêterez trop vite d'essayer ou vous n'essayerez même pas.
Et alors, vous serez encore plus convaincus de ne pas pouvoir réussir.
Et c'est pour ça que tant de gens sont en dessous de leur vrai potentiel.
Parce-que sur leur chemin, quelque-part, parfois un seul échec,
les a convaincu qu'ils ne pouvaient pas réussir, et ils y ont cru.
Quand on est convaincu de quelque-chose, c'est très difficile de changer d'avis.
J'ai appris cette leçon "à la dure" quand j'étais adolescent, avec mon frère.
Une nuit, on était en voiture avec des amis, sur une route mal éclairée,
quand une voiture de police nous a arrêté.
Il y avait eu un cambriolage pas loin, ils cherchaient des suspects.
L'officier s'est approché de la voiture, il a éclairé le conducteur avec sa torche,
puis il a éclairé mon frère, sur le siège passager, devant, et enfin moi.
Et il m'a demandé, les yeux grand-ouverts :
« Où est-ce que j'ai déjà vu ta tête ? »
(Rires)
Et j'ai répondu : « Sur le siège passager, devant. »
Mais ça n'a eu aucun sens pour lui, à l'évidence.
Donc il a pensé que je m'étais drogué.
(Rires)
Donc il m'extirpe de la voiture, me fouille,
m'escorte jusqu'à la voiture de police,
et seulement après s'être assuré que je n'avais pas de casier,
il m'a laissé lui montrer que j'avais bien un frère jumeau sur le siège passager.
Mais même pendant qu'on s'éloignait, on pouvait voir par son expression
qu'il était convaincu que je l'avais roulé.
On a du mal à changer d'avis quand on est convaincu.
Donc il est très naturel d'être démoralisé et de se sentir vaincu après un échec.
Mais on ne peut pas se permettre de se convaincre qu'on ne peut pas réussir.
Il faut se battre contre les sentiments d'impuissance.
Il faut reprendre le contrôle de la situation.
Et il faut briser ce genre de cycles négatifs avant qu'ils ne commencent.
Nos pensées et nos sentiments,
ce ne sont pas les amis dignes de confiance qu'on croyait.
Ce sont plutôt des amis à l'humeur changeante,
qui peuvent être de bon soutien une minute et vraiment désagréable la suivante.
Une fois, j'ai travaillé avec cette dame qui,
après 20 ans de mariage et un mauvais -très mauvais- divorce,
était enfin prête pour son premier rendez-vous galant.
Elle avait rencontré le gars en ligne, et il avait l'air sympa, d'avoir bien réussi,
et le plus important, elle avait l'air de vraiment lui plaire.
Donc elle était très excitée, elle a acheté une nouvelle robe,
et ils se sont retrouvés dans un bar chic de New-York pour boire un verre.
Au bout de dix minutes, le gars s'est levé, et il a dit :
« Je ne suis pas intéressé. » Et il est sorti.
Le rejet est extrêmement douloureux.
La dame avait si mal qu'elle ne pouvait pas bouger. Elle n'a pu qu'appeler un ami.
Voici ce que l'ami a répondu : « Bah, tu t'attends à quoi ?
T'as de grosses fesses, t'as rien d'intéressant à dire,
pourquoi est-ce qu'un bel homme, un homme qui réussi comme lui,
aurait envie de sortir avec une perdante comme toi ? »
Choquant, non, qu'un ami puisse être aussi cruel ?
Mais ça serait beaucoup moins choquant
si je vous disait que ce n'est pas l'ami qui lui a dit ça.
C'est ce que la dame s'est dit à elle-même.
Et c'est quelque-chose que nous faisons tous, surtout après avoir été rejeté.
On commence tous à penser à tous nos défauts, à toutes nos lacunes,
à ce qu'on veut être, à ce qu'on ne veut plus être,
on s'insulte.
Peut-être pas aussi méchamment, mais c'est ce qu'on fait tous.
C'est intéressant qu'on le fasse parce que notre amour-propre nous fait déjà mal.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on voudrait l’endommager encore plus ?
On n'aggraverait pas exprès une blessure physique.
On ne dirait pas, après s'être coupé le bras : « Ah, je sais !
Je vais prendre un couteau, voir jusqu'où je peux aller avec cette coupure. »
Mais c'est ce qu'on fait toujours avec les blessures psychologiques.
Pourquoi ? A cause d'une mauvaise hygiène émotionnelle.
Parce qu'on ne fait pas passer notre santé psychologique avant tout.
On sait grâce à des dizaines d'études que quand notre amour-propre est au plus bas,
on est plus vulnérable au stress et à l'anxiété,
les échecs et les rejets font plus de mal, et il faut plus longtemps pour en guérir.
Donc quand vous êtes rejetés, la première chose à faire,
c'est de ranimer votre amour-propre, pas de le réduire en purée.
Quand vous souffrez émotionnellement,
traitez-vous avec la même compassion que vous attendriez d'un vrai, bon ami.
Il faut prendre nos mauvaises habitudes psychologique, et les changer.
L'une des plus mauvaises et des plus communes, c'est la rumination.
Ruminer signifie cogiter.
C'est quand votre patron vous crie dessus, ou que votre professeur se moque de vous,
ou quand vous vous disputez avec un ami,
et que vous ne pouvez plus arrêter de repasser la scène dans votre tête,
pendant des jours, des fois des semaines à la suite.
Ruminer comme ça, pour des évènements pénibles, peut vite devenir une habitude,
une habitude qui coûte très cher.
Parce qu'en étant aussi souvent concentré sur des pensées pénibles, négatives,
vous vous exposez à un risque réel
de faire une dépression, de devenir alcoolique,
d'avoir des troubles de l'alimentation, et même des maladies cardiovasculaires.
Le problème c'est que le besoin de ruminer peut se faire très fort et important,
donc c'est une habitude difficile à arrêter.
Je le sais très bien, parce qu'il y a un peu plus d'un an,
j'ai pris cette habitude moi-même.
On avait diagnostiqué à mon frère un lymphome non-hodgkinien de phase 3.
Son cancer était très aggressif.
Il avait des tumeurs visibles sur tout son corps.
Et il a du se lancer dans une chimiothérapie qui a été très dure.
Et je ne pouvais pas arrêter de penser à tout ce qu'il subissait.
Je ne pouvais pas arrêter de me dire qu'il souffrait.
même s'il ne s'est jamais plaint, pas une seule fois.
Il avait cette attitude incroyablement positive.
Sa santé psychologique était impressionnante.
J'étais en bonne santé physique, mais psychologiquement, je n'étais plus rien.
Mais j'ai su quoi faire.
Des études disent qu'une distraction, même de deux minutes, suffit
à interrompre le besoin de ruminer à ce moment précis.
Donc, chaque fois que j'avais une pensée inquiétante, douloureuse, négative,
je me forçais à me concentrer sur autre chose jusqu'à ce que le besoin s'en aille.
Et en une semaine, toute ma vision des choses a changé
et je suis devenu plus positif, et j'avais plus d'espoir.
Après 9 semaines de chimiothérapie, mon frère a passé un scanner,
et j'étais avec lui quand il a eu les résultats.
Toutes les tumeurs avaient disparu.
Il avait encore trois cures de chimiothérapie à faire,
mais il savait qu'il allait guérir.
Cette photo a été prise il y a deux semaines.
En agissant quand on est seul,
en changeant nos réponses à l'échec,
en protégeant notre amour-propre,
en se battant contre les pensées négatives,
on ne se contente pas de soigner nos blessures psychologiques,
on construit une résistance émotionnelle, et on prospère.
Il y a cent ans, les gens ont commencé à avoir une hygiène personnelle,
et l’espérance de vie a augmenté de plus de 50%
en seulement quelques décennies.
Je suis persuadé que notre qualité de vie pourrait augmenter aussi vite
si nous commencions tous à avoir une hygiène émotionnelle.
Vous imaginez à quoi le monde ressemblerait
si tout le monde était en meilleure forme psychologique ?
S'il y avait moins de solitude, et moins de dépression ?
Si les gens savaient comment vaincre l'échec ?
S'ils étaient plus fiers d'eux, et s'ils se sentaient plus forts ?
S'ils étaient plus heureux et plus épanouis ?
Moi j'imagine, parce que c'est le monde dans lequel je veux vivre,
et c'est le monde dans lequel mon frère lui aussi veut vivre.
Et si en vous informant, vous pouvez changer quelques simples habitudes,
eh bien, c'est le monde dans lequel nous pouvons tous vivre.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)